[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno antes que nada buenas noches a
todos
gracias por las pruebas a más de uno
gracias a la organización antes que nada
por ahora limitado
estoy muy orgulloso de formar parte de
esto y muy contento aunque lo parezca
porque antes que nada voy a presentar mi
nombre es joaquín lópez más conexión
juaco lópez lópez jugar al canal de
juega como el flaquito de los encontró
hoy es el primer paso de uno de los
proyectos más grandes que tengo en mi
vida
por eso contento de estar acá algunos
pensarán que va a ser algo gracioso ayer
tuvo rock
hoy vengo a hablar básicamente de dos
cosas muy importantes en mi vida
y como casi arruinó mi vida
y como llegué a salvarla
para casi arruinar mi vida necesite de
una sola persona que soy yo
para salvar la necesite de muchas
así que lo que básicamente en un
principio de adicciones de una adicción
más que nada
de la cocaína una adicción que casi
llegó a la destrucción total de mi
familia
y lo digo sin busco para que deje de ser
un tema tabú la cocaína que realmente se
tiene que charlar con esta fluidez para
que las personas que realmente la
necesitan la ayuda se las podamos
brindar
porque realmente la gente que está
metida ahí les puedo asegurar de mi
luming del lugar que no quieren estar
ahí nadie quiere estar en ese lugar
yo tenía 16 años y una debilidad mental
muy fuerte cuando me tomé la primera
línea de marca
estaba en el secundario tenía un padre
ausente una hermana con su familia
formada
y una mamá que se puso una vida al
hombre una familia nombró un hijo
adolescente
30 años de golpes encima
y casi 12 horas de trabajo por día para
poder sacar una familia adelante
o sea que básicamente yo estaba en la
calle casi todo el día
más allá de las charlas de noches
enteras y consejos diarias de mi vieja
quién es mi mejor amiga decirme por
dónde ir que estudie pero que no meta en
la calle que lamenta la droga
con un niño adolescente rebelde y
mentalmente débil experimente bastos
sólo una línea de verdad para entrar y
no poder salir
siendo muy chico también es muy difícil
al punto de crear me está más vivo que
un trance de la villa zavaleta para los
que no saben lo que es un francés el que
comercializa la droga para lo que no
saben lo que es tabletas una la villa
más peligrosa algunos aires
y con 16 años un domingo a las 7 de la
mañana me vinieron a buscar tres tipos
me pusieron el arma en el pecho dijeron
dónde está la plata que si no me van a
pegar un tiro
ahí fue donde pensé que había hecho el
clip
nos buscaban a mí ya un compañero de ese
momento con quien no tengo ningún rencor
y le mando un fuerte abrazo sin
argumentos llega a ver esto lo
importante que lo estamos a salvo
nos dieron hasta esa noche para
conseguir la plata que debíamos
o claramente ahora consecuencia de las
cuales podría salir lastimado yo a mi
familia la familia de él
conseguimos la plata mi vieja y yo nos
jugamos
veíamos en villa domínico ese momento
nos vamos a wilder
y yo durante un año y medio dos nunca
más volví a saber nada
la reina a los 18 o 19 años ya
trabajando en un call center haciendo
más grande vuelvo a tener una recaída
muy grande
la cual fue vital la presencia de mi
pareja en ese momento que faustina
y mi mamá y mis amigos
ya de grande es es otro el tema ya
trabajando teniendo plata encima
es como un poco más difícil salir de las
adicciones o de esa adicción en este
caso
supere y cuando volví a recaer el clic
en mi cabeza lo hice cuando hablé con mi
vieja y le dije que había vuelto a
recaer porque había gastado plata que
teníamos que pagar deudas
pero la noche de gira
y mi vieja callo
tumbada en el piso básicamente
arrodillada
llorando pidiéndome perdón
diciéndome
que la culpa la tenía ella por no haber
estado cuando cuando la necesite
y ahí fue donde me di cuenta que no era
lo que eso quería para mi vida
porque no ella no tuvo la culpa
como va a tener la culpa una mina que la
grava 12 horas por día y que hasta a
veces no comía para pagarme la escuela o
no sé nada para qué
para que se coman básicamente y que fue
una de las pocas que en ese momento me
ven a mano porque más de uno también me
dio la espalda
en ese momento
por eso para salir de eso necesiten
mucho amor voluntad propia mucho apoyo
necesite de mis amigos
para arruinar la necesite yo solo
solamente mis decisiones y para salir de
eso
necesite de mucho apoyo
esa fue la última vez que tomé cocaína
pero no todo terminó ahí porque en torno
mío sea y ahí adentro hoy día la siguen
peleando para salir de eso y trato de
ayudar todo el tiempo
porque sé lo que es estar ahí
si alguien te dice está ahí porque
quiere usted porque le gusta de mentira
porque te gustan estas porque lo que
eres
al poco tiempo de eso salimos como
pudimos con mi vieja del pozo empezamos
a pagar deudas a tapar agujeros y me
volví a tocar en mi vida con piano
algunos lo conocerán mi mejor amigo de
toda la vida con quien pase en mejores
años del secundario
y me había distanciado en ese año tan
difícil para mí y me había distanciado
de él me vuelvo a cruzar en la vida con
él y me lo topo con su stream con el que
yo no conocía algo el cual él me obliga
a aparecer
forzadamente aparecí nació la dupla y
empezamos a trabajar juntos
pasamos de la casa de él y su familia a
un ambiente en caballito donde nos
quedamos de frío en los campos de calor
nos quedamos risa todo el 2019 creando
contenidos juntos conseguimos contratos
con plataformas conseguimos contratos
con equipos con el equipo de informarán
de latinoamérica aquí podéis probar los
que no saben es un equipo de deportes
electrónicos los contrató como creadores
de contenido la gente no es eta quien
también hemos de un fuerte abrazo
fuimos a los quads 2019 para los que no
saben a los cuales la comunidad
streamers argentina más grande del país
y una de las más grandes de
latinoamérica yo fui la promesa ganamos
la mejor dupla no somos un montón de
premios
durante todo el 2020 también trabajamos
juntos conseguimos una casa para salir
con nuestros amigos la esquina
los costos mejoró el 2020 la casa se
hizo muchos premios y todo fue felicidad
aquí voy con esto que que para llegar a
donde estoy hoy hacer uno de los
estrenos más reconocidos del continente
también existe amor voluntad y apoyo yo
creo que son tres cosas vitales que no
pueden faltar mi vida cambió en un abrir
y cerrar de ojos si yo no hubiese tenido
amor voluntad propia sobre todo y apoyo
de mis familiares y amigos
probablemente la estaría hablando con
ustedes
[Música]
aquí voy con esto
es muy necesario tener esas tres cosas
para lo que sería ya sea para salir una
edición o para perseguir un sueño
y por eso digo a los padres apoyen a sus
hijos
escuchen a sus hijos no saben por lo que
pueden estar pasando de verdad una
debilidad mental no es un óvulo es la
salud mental es de las cosas más
importantes
en la vida necesita ser fuerte
mentalmente para poder seguir adelante
dejen lo que parecía en su sueño
déjenlos que fracasen acompáñenos en el
fracaso también porque no estaba en
fracasar lo que está mal es pensar que
el sueño se va a cumplir sí o sí
el sueño probablemente no se cumpla
probablemente fracases
pero ahí está dónde vas a encontrar otro
rumbo yo soñaba con ser jugador de
fútbol no iba a llegar nunca tengo dos
pies izquierdos
pero me topé con el stream y el
verdadero sueño que estoy viviendo hoy
cumpliendo ya mi vieja dándole la
tranquilidad que le rodea durante muchos
años noches enteras sin dormir no sé sin
tele sonando pensando en mi enorme
tranquilo le puedo pasar sus vacaciones
le puedo pagar su casa
puedo darle a mis sobrinos lo que les
falta agustín santiago de catalina que
son la luz en mis ojos básicamente a mi
hermana también que es mi compañera de
que nací
y con esto digo a los padres también
apoyen lo en todo hoy día veo muchos
padres que nos miran de reojo lo que
hacemos nosotros
andá a buscar una pala no sabes lo que
se va a elaborar lo escucharon todos
lados del extreme de creador de
contenido en youtube o en cualquier
plataforma no es una boludez es un
trabajo y les puedo asegurar que
trabajamos hasta más que muchos que
están en la tele que nos producen todos
nosotros vamos nuestros canales solitos
y abajo nos ayudó nadie hasta donde
estamos hoy si ambos solos con este
trabajo obviamente que después viene la
ayuda de marcas y lo que sea pero hasta
acá llegamos sólo aprendimos una cama
una computadora y le pedíamos de abajo
nosotros solitos
escuchen a sus hijos apoyen lo sobre
todas las cosas dejen lo que intenten y
dejen los que fracasen
que de eso se trata la vida si no tienes
un fracaso no no es vida
lo que está mal es pensar que el sueño
suele cumplirse así porque ahí es donde
se derrumba mentalmente si eso no se
cumple probablemente no se cumpla y vas
a encontrar otros rumbos para seguir
con esto finalizó mi charla diciéndole a
todos que también pongan más atención en
la nueva era digital la nueva la
entretenimiento que se viene que son las
plataformas de streaming denle una
oportunidad seguramente de lo que a
ustedes les entretenga en tweets van a
encontrar más de mil canales haciendo lo
mismo y dejemos el monopolio de la
televisión de un lado que hay que ver
siempre lo que te imponen si quería
darle las gracias a la organización
gracias a toda la gente de chubut por el
amor
mi nombre es joaquín lópez represento mi
rival llanera ya todos los pibes de
abajo que alguna vez nos miran normal
por estar vencido por tener las
zapatillas rotas una gorrita o nos
señalaron diciendo éste pide no vale dos
mangos hoy yo estoy acá y valgo más que
eso
muchas veces a todos
[Música]
[Aplausos]